عبر وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي اف جالانت عن
موقف من السلطه الفلسطينيه يعد النقيض لما
سبق لرئيس الوزراء نتنياهو تكراره
والالحاح عليه حيث قال جالانت ان وجود
سلطه فلسطينيه قويه هو مصلحه امنيه
اسرائيليه وذلك في وقت شدد فيه نتنياهو
على رفض اي دور للسلطه في مستقبل القطاع
بعد الحرب وقد حذر جالنت من انفجار
الاوضاع في الضف
جراء منع دخول العمال الفلسطينيين الى
اسرائيل واستمرار منع تحويل اموال المقاصه
الفلسطينيه منذ السابع من
اكتوبر معنا من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري اهلا بك وليد ضعنا في
سياقات هذه التصريحات المتناقضه والمواقف
المتباينه بخصوص وضع السلطه الفلسطينيه في
قطاع غزه بعد الحرب
هذا تجسيد اضافي
للخلافات التي تتحكم بدوائر صنع القرار في
اسرائيل تصريحات وزير الدفاع جلان جاءت
بعد تقييم امني حضره مع كبار الضباط في
منطقه قياده المنطقه الشماليه في الجيش
الاسرائيلي المسؤوله عن الضفه الغربيه حيث
قال بان الاوضاع في الضفه الغربيه على شفا
الانفجار وان اسرائيل ملزمه بان تقوم
بتحرير الاموال التي تحتجزها وهي موال
عائدات الضرائب المستحقه للسلطه
الفلسطينيه والسماح للعمال الفلسطينيين من
الضفه الغربيه بالدخول الى داخل اسرائيل
للعمل لان سلطه فلسطينيه قويه هي مصلحه
امنيه اسرائيليه تصريحات جلنت هذه لا
تتوافق مع موقف رئيس الحكومه نتنياهو
وكذلك مع التوام سموتريتش بنفير وهم الذين
اخذوا القرار باحتجاز هذه الاموال بل ذهبت
الامور الى ابعد من ذلك حيث بدا الجيش
الاسرائيلي حتى ب مداهمه المنازل وقرصنه
اموال فيها مثل راتب عائلتي
وزوجه مجدي الريماوي المعتقل منذ اكثر من
20 عاما ومدان على خلفيه قيام خليه من
الجبهه الشعبيه باغتيال الجنرال احتياط
الوزير في حكومه شارون في حينه رحبعام زئي
انتقاما على قيام على اغتيال انتقاما
لاغتيال اسرائيل للامين العام للجبهه
الشعبيه في حينه ابو علي مصطفى عمليه
قرصنه اموال ال العائدات الضرائب المستحقه
للجانب الفلسطيني ايضا الولايات المتحده
تدخلت فيها يتذرع الاسرائيليون بانهم
يقومون بذلك لمنع تحويلها تحويل جزء كبير
منها الى المواطنين في قطاع غزه من ذوي
الشهداء والاسرى وايضا الموظفين هناك وهذا
الموضوع يثقل على السلطه الفلسطينيه هذا
يعكس جانبا من الخلافات المتواصله داخل
دوائر صنع القرار اخرها كان هذه الليله
ودار حول مساله ابرام صفقه تبادل للاسرى
مع حركه حماس حيث كان هناك موقف للوزيرين
من معسكر الدوله بيني جانس
وجابي جادي ايزنكوت ايز ق قال انه ان
الاوان ان نكف عن الكذب على انفسنا علينا
الذهاب الى صفقه حتى لو كان الثمن باهظ
لكن وايده في ذلك الوزير جانس لكن رئيس
الحكومه نتنياهو وكذلك جلنت رفضوا هذا
الموقف وقالوا بانه يجب الاستمرار فيما
يصفونه بعمليه الضغط العسكري على حماس كي
تتقدم بمشروع اقتراح يتيح ذلك هذا عكس ان
المفاوضات ومن خلال الوسطاء سواء القطريين
المصريين ام الامريكيين هي عالقه ولم تحقق
اي اختراق بهذا الشان وياتي هذا كله ايضا
لامتداد لحاله التوتر التي تتحكم بدوائر
صنع القرار في اسرائيل والتي كانت قد سجلت
ذروه امس الاول في اجتماع مجلس الحرب في
تل ابيب عندما ابعد نتنياهو ومنع دخول
مدير مكتب وزير الدفاع جلنت وجزمه على
الخروج فغضب جلنت وخرج وانسحب هو الاخر
وقبل ثلاثه ايام من ذلك كان هناك ما يشبه
المسرحيه او السرك حسب الاسرائيليين في
اجتماع المجلس الوزاري الامن السياسي
المصغر المعروف بالكابينه عندما بدات
وزيره مقربه من نتنياهو ووزير مقرب منه
ايضا واعلنت لدى وصول وزير الدفاع جلنت
بانه قد بدات المسرحيه وبدات بتوزيع
الفشار او البوب كورن على زملاء ها بينما
هاجم الوزير الاخر وهو ام سالم وبني جانس
بما يشير الى وكان جانس متهم بتسريب
معلومات من داخل هذه الاجتماع هذه الامور
بمجملها وتعود ايضا للهجوم الذي كان على
رئيس هيئه الاركان العسكريه من وزراء
مقربين من نتنياهو ومن اليمين العنصري قبل
نحو ع ايام هذه في مجملها تعكس ان هناك
حاله من الارباك في داخل دوائر صنع الق
الاسرائيليه وهو ما يزيد من انعدام الثقه
في الشارع الاسرائيلي
تجاه صناع القرار على المستوى السياسي
تحديدا لدرجه ان نتنياهو الذي دعاه ذو
الاسرى المحتجزين في قطاع غزه للحضور الى
المظاهره الكبيره التي اجروها امس والوقفه
التي استمرت 100 دقيقه في اشاره الى 100
يوم للحرب لاحتجازه في غزه لم يجرؤ لا هو
ولا اي من وزرائه على الاقتراب من هذه
التظاهرات التي اشار اشير الى ان نحو 300
ال من الاسرائيليين شاركوا فيها وان بعضها
مثل مظاهره حيفا رفع لافتات تطالب باقاله
نتنياهو وحكومته
وذهب نحو 171 ضابطا وجنرال سابقا ورئيسا
لاجهزه امن كبيره مثل الشباك والموساد الى
التوقيع على عريضه تطالب باجراء انتخابات
مبكره واسقاط هذه الحكومه اقامه حكومه
اخرى بدلها هذا كله يترافق مع معلومات
تتسرب من الولايات المتحده تناقلتها وسائل
اعلام امريكيه واسرائيليه بان الرئيس
بايدن قد ضاق ذرعا بنتنياهو وبطريقه تصرفه
خلال هذه الحرب وكان قبل وصول وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه بلينكن الى البلاد في
زيارته الاخيره الاسبوع الماضي قد وصلت
معلومات تقول بان الاداره الامريكيه قد
المحت الى
بانه بان عليه ان يختار اما
ان ينحاز الى بنفير وسموت المتطرفان او ان
الدعم الامريكي له في هذه الحرب قد يتراجع
او يفقده نهائيا وليد العمري مدير مكتبنا
من رام الله شكرا جزيلا لك